[Music]
thank you
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
program I'd like to know this is a
question and answer program where those
who watch the program send us their
questions we do the research and if
there is an answer in the Bible we try
and find it and answer it on the
following programs we are thankful that
you decided to join us today and if you
want to send us your questions let me
give you the address it'll be on the
screen TV at some tv.org once again TV
at some
tv.org you know we have this program in
Spanish and also in English we receive
many many questions in Spanish we don't
receive as many questions in English so
I want to encourage those who are
English speaking to please send us your
questions we would be delighted to
answer those questions here on the air
by the way my name is Stephen Bohr I'm
the president of Secrets unsealed and
have with me
David Salazar the newest addition to
Secrets unsealed and we're so glad that
he's here thank you he's a Workhorse
thank you and as a wonderful family wife
two daughters and uh it's a real
pleasure to have you here with us Pastor
Salazar thank you Pastor board a
blessing to be here and share this space
with you praise the lord well we want to
have a word of Prayer and then we want
to get right into our program today we
have several very interesting questions
so would you please pray for us yes
Pastor let's pray
Heavenly Father we thank you Lord for
the opportunity that you give us to come
together and to Scott discuss and try to
answer some of the questions that our
friends who are watching have sent we
know that we are not really anything but
without your strength with your wisdom
with your holy spirit so we pray that
now you will grant us a portion of the
holy spirit that our answers may come
from your word and may be of
encouragement and of blessing to those
that are watching we pray all this in
Jesus name amen you know sometimes we
get questions where there is not a clear
biblical answer to the question uh and
so we have to apply principles in that
case right and the first question that
we have today is probably one of those
questions where there is not a direct
biblical answer and we have to appeal to
principles it says I'd like to know if
being a house husband
or a stay-at-home dad is unbiblical or
if it displeases God even though it
could be more convenient that way in all
senses even spiritually
for that specific household
especially when taking into
consideration spouses strengths and
weaknesses not to mention their
interests preferences and agreements in
doing some duties and responsibilities
wouldn't that be good stewardship of
their talents and resources that God
gave them wouldn't that bring glory to
God so what can we say regarding
principles concerning uh you know who
should stay at home with the kids and
who should keep the house in order and
so on what principles could we apply to
answer this question well Pastor Moore I
believe that the principles are defined
by the Lord himself in the Book of
Genesis we certainly know that the Lord
intended for the marriage of a man and a
woman to be a family of
of equals but of different roles even
before the same came to this world now
when sin came to the world
um we realized that God In His Infinite
Wisdom provided a specific even more
direct roles and positions within the
marriage you know atmosphere the
marriage
Institution for a man and for the woman
and one of the things that he mentions
there to Adam was that he was to be the
provider of the home he had to sweat it
was a it was a curse but in a way it's
actually a blessing for him it was a
blessing of responsibility of doing what
he would keep him occupied BC and what
it was necessary for his character to
develop as a man that would provide so
the concept in the Bible is from the
very beginning you know that a man
should be the
breadwinning if you will the one that
provides for the family and
the woman her role was to be the mother
of children I mean her main or her more
important role not that she cannot do
anything else but it's her her best
uh uh role I I suppose for her as a
woman and therefore I think that we have
to be very careful when we put
situations like this or you know if a
house husband or a stay-home dad is you
know something that is approved today or
not I mean the question is a little
difficult because there might be
exception to the rule or exceptions to
these situations or circumstances that
could make a person not able to work but
overall I think Pastor you know the
principles in the Bible do apply that
man should be the ones who should work
make the living hood for the family
and the woman to be more uh taking care
of their children and be the mother of
in the home yeah if I could share my own
personal experience
um
I had a mother who never worked outside
the home
she she was a stay-at-home mom
I have three sisters
and um we didn't turn out too bad
for sure of course that depends on who
you ask yeah but but you know we had a
special attachment towards our mother
absolutely our mother was not uh the
go-getter she wasn't uh you know the
administrator of the finances and things
like that uh she didn't work outside the
home but she had that softer side Ellen
White says that the the husband is to be
the disciplinarian
the mother has more of a softer side
right and even though I loved both of my
parents they passed away I had a special
attachment to my mother right because
she stayed at home she had the softer
side you know she counseled in a softer
voice than my dad my dad was the
disciplinarian and and so when God
created Adam and Eve he created them
equal right but with different functions
as you were mentioning right now can
there be exceptions to the rule I
believe that there can be exceptions to
the rule what would be some of those
exceptions for example if the the
husband gets ill or has an accident of
some sort and he cannot longer work or
has a temporary you know situation where
he's Health prevents him from going and
earning the living hood of the family
then you could say a woman could step in
that direction and help out but it's not
ideal as you mentioned is probably
situations that are temporary or
exceptions to the rule necessarily you
know but it's not it's not to be the you
know the mainstream of most cases or
perhaps you know if the husband loses
the job and the wife uh you know the
wife has the academic preparation to
step in and find a job meanwhile right I
think that would be an exception to the
rule but as a rule God made man and
woman to fulfill different roles
yet complementary absolutely in marriage
particularly when there are children in
the household
and there might be exceptional cases
where that would not be the ideal but
those would be the exception not the
rule absolutely absolutely Pastor so I
pray that our friend yariel can um
see the principle there you know and
apply to to his question yeah all right
Pastor so we have the next question uh
let's moving on with the next question
this is also a very interesting question
a little bit uh one of those questions
that we might not be able to uh perhaps
understand it fully as we are learning
about it a little bit but it says the
following question says a friend of a
friend experienced
and be known to her a healing from
sounds like Reiki I think I'm selling
that right I'm not sure
when she realized what had happened her
back was to the person she was upset it
worked in her and wanted to know why it
did
and she mentions that that person was a
always an SDA and also some sort of
evangelist so
um I guess it's an interesting question
Pastor have you ever heard of this
Reiki method of healing you know I have
heard uh on television using sounds
for people to be able to go to sleep
yeah uh quicker and to have a more
restful sleep there might be something
to that no music can't be soothing right
you remember the case of Saul when the
spirit tormented song and David played
his harp I mean that was soothing and it
calmed him so God has created Music you
know to help people in times of trial
and tribulation and so on but there are
some types of alternative uh medicine if
you please right that are questionable
like for example iridiology you know
trying to determine illnesses by the
iris of the eye uh acupuncture uh yoga
meditation
Transcendental Meditation Etc where
people people in some of these things
their mind is not under control I mean
their mind is not controlling their
thought processes because really they're
they're out of it and then I would say
that in those cases
um it would not be wise uh to to
practice those things absolutely there
was I just trying to find a little bit
about this this type of healing it's it
sounds to me you know that it is a
technique of relaxation and they
introduce a lot of these ideas of energy
coming through the body and heal or
leading the energy you know as these
some of these uh Eastern type of healing
process are are often the case but as
you mentioned there are types that are
may have some sort of effect and it
might have worked because again the uses
methods techniques that help the body to
relax but that doesn't mean necessarily
that that person should be necessarily
um I guess worry that an evil spirit
came into her or something like that I
think that maybe that's her worry in
that regard nevertheless we have to
remind people that there's a quote from
Ellen G white
I'll try to really read it to to to our
listeners and audience it's found in uh
first uh sorry testimonies to the church
volume Five
and
um
I just okay and then uh page 443 and I
read there are many ways of practicing
The Healing Art so there are many ways
of practicing The Healing Art but there
is only one way that heaven approves
God's remedies are the simple agencies
of nature that will not tax or
debilitate the system through their
powerful properties and then she lists
them pure air and water cleanliness a
proper diet purity of life and a firm
trust in God are remedies for the one of
which thousands are dying yet these
remedies are going out of date because
they're skillful use requires work that
the people do not appreciate
fresh air exercise pure water and clean
sweet premises are within the reach of
all but little expense but drugs are
expensive both in the outlay of means
and in the effect produced upon the
system so here the spirit prophecy lays
out that there are many methods of
healing or many ways of practicing
Health healing but there's only one that
haven't approved and is the one that he
has laid out in the natural lifestyle
experiences that we can do you know the
choices of choosing the right type of
food a type of exercise we do with the
type of air that we breathe you know
resting and all those things that we
know the eight laws of health so I think
pasta we can you know help them remember
that it's important that we go by the
method that will Heaven approves and
know these other ideas or concepts that
may have an effect they may be seem to
work but ultimately they're not really
leading us to the way that the Lord
wants us to heal you know unfortunately
people many people these days they want
quick solutions to complex problems
um you know when people have a headache
they say well you know just take a
Tylenol uh if you have a stomachache
well Pepto-Bismol will do it you know
because the instead of instead of
changing the lifestyle you know the
lifestyle is what determines the health
that you're going to have absolutely the
the natural remedies that you mentioned
but it takes work right and it takes
discipline it's not something that
happens quickly that's right you know
like for example if you're overweight
and uh and you know you need to or you
have diabetes or something it takes
effort to get back on track right
um and uh and people just don't want to
put forth the effort they want quick
solutions to their problems and that
might be this Reiki which is mentioned
here you know which inadvertently
happened I don't think that if it
happened inadvertently that this person
is under any threat of the devil or
anything because you know it's only when
you consciously do something like that
that it might might be a problem so you
know I think that we need to stick with
the methods that God has given the only
one which you read to recover health and
to preserve our health amen amen Pastor
I think that makes perfect sense okay
now let's take a look at our next
question uh this is a very interesting
one you know one of the problems in the
world today is that there's not very
much modesty around
and this one has to do with Christian
modesty yes my name and I'm not going to
read the name but the person is from
Ethiopia
and my question is about Christian
Recreation
according to the spirit of Prophecy
Recreation is the
re-creation of mind and body
however nowadays
Recreations common in the world are
being adopted in Christianity
we can see people
and then in parentheses men and women
almost naked on the beaches with their
underwear only in public
does God endorse such a recreation and
should we do this as a Christian well
pastor this is uh like you mentioned you
know the there is probably today at too
much modesty uh in in in the world as a
general unfortunately it has also come
into Christendom
and even people from our own church have
no real idea of what it's it how
eventually it has I believe that
um as this brother here has mentioned
about Christian Recreation the spirit
prophecy clearly indicates that it is
not only a privilege but a duty for us
to have Recreation not to tax our minds
or our bodies if we're working you know
variously or your mind if you're working
always in research or study that you
need to have time to re generate
recreate your body so it's important to
go and experience that but we have to
choose the right ones I mean the right
places to go unfortunately some of these
places that are very nice and I love
going to the ocean and going to the
beach personally I love that since I was
a child but if a place that is filled
with things that are
you know or people who are not honoring
God by covering themselves then it's
best to avoid them places and I think
that we need to keep that in mind uh we
I know that in the in the Bible
nakedness is a sign of of rebellion of
sin so we don't want to dishonor the
Lord by you know by taking or
participating in those events so I
believe that the answer as this brother
is seeking is definitely not the place
Ambitions for Christians to be or
children of God to be exposed or be in
that situation
I think the principle is the principle
of modesty right and everybody has to be
sincere with themselves
you know we can try and justify things
that we do
but we should be sincere and say Speak
Lord let me know whether this is really
something that I should do as a
Christian or not
um I think that the principle is
expressed in a couple of texts that we
find in the New Testament and this is
just talking about the principle and I
think that the principle would apply to
men and not only to women absolutely
even though women are the subject of the
passage that I'm going to read right in
First Peter chapter 3 verse 1 wives
likewise be submissive to your own
husbands that even if some do not obey
the word they without a word may be won
by the conduct of their wives when they
observe your chaste conduct accompanied
by fear do not let your adornment be
and the word merely is added there
it's in italics in the King James when
it's in italics you know they're trying
to justify well it doesn't be you know
you need to have this but you know you
can also have this uh so it says
um do not let your adornment be merely
oh added uh it really says adornment be
outward arranging the hair wearing gold
or putting on fine apparel now that
doesn't describe someone who is at the
beach right but a person who comes to
the beach with revealing more than what
is hidden is really
is really violating this principle of
modesty absolutely you know they're
trying to attract attention to
themselves and then it says in verse 4
rather let it be the hidden person of
the heart right with The Incorruptible
beauty of a gentle and quiet Spirit
which is very precious in the sight of
God and then it says for in this manner
in former times the holy women who
trusted in God also adorned themselves
being submission submissive to their own
husbands absolutely and then the Apostle
Paul measures in as well I believe it's
in first sit First Timothy chapter two
uh in verse verse 9
uh it says in like manner also that
women Adorn themselves in modest apparel
that would apply to going to the beach
right in modest apparel with propriety
and moderation
not with braided hair or gold or pearls
or costly clothing
but which is proper for men women
professing godliness with good works
and so the principle is we should not
attract attention to ourselves we should
remember that we are representatives of
Christ and the way we dress speaks
volumes about our relationship with
Jesus Christ and I think that would be
the principle that would be applied when
we decide to go to the beach where
there's that kind of of attire or going
to the movie theater or going anyplace
it would be the principle absolutely the
principle and I think that as mentioned
Pastor you know the the concept of where
we need to be where we need to go for
recreation it has to be where we give
glory and honor to the Lord in
everything that we do if the Lord's
presence can be in there and and really
we can sense that connection with God
it's is a place where we can safely
enjoy ourselves and participate in
Recreation but if we go to a an
amusement place or something that is not
conducive to us to connect with God then
the likelihood we are in the wrong place
we're not partaking of of the experience
and this can translate even in the way
and you know maybe I'm going off of the
track here but you know even the Way
That We Gather for for worship
experiences for you know things of
church Gatherings and things that kind
of nature we have to be very careful
that we are not participating or
encouraging our young people to go to a
place or to be in an environment that it
really disconnects them from the
presence of God so amen amen important
well we have one more question that we
have time for and this question comes
from a
16-year-old person wow from Andrew wow
you want to read that yes Pastor let me
read this for you for you it says hello
pastors I have a question concerning the
study of God's word and the spirit of
Prophecy
in my young Journey on studying God's
word I have come across some difficult
things to understand in the scriptures
although I am only 16 years old I want
to have a better study life for I know
that God is preparing me for something
big
my desire is to study the scriptures
appropriately but sometimes it is
difficult to fully comprehend many
important topics I've also been reading
LNG white books on the Life of Christ
and prophecy and I have found many
Eternal truths in her writings and I
would like to compare her Guidance with
the scriptures that I may fully be
convinced of the things which she writes
so I'd like to know how to study God's
word and Ellen White's books thanks
okay first of all we need to
congratulate this uh young uh Andrew
Andrew
for saying that God has something big
for him praise the Lord amen and that
someone at this age is really interested
in studying the scriptures so what could
we recommend to Andrew to understand
better the Bible and the spirit of
Prophecy is that you know Pastor I
believe that as you mentioned the young
man wanting to study scriptures is
really almost unheard of it nowadays A
lot of times young people at age are
interested in anything but the
scriptures nevertheless God is working
the hearts of young men and women I'm
sure and this is an example of the
spirit of God impressing the young minds
and young hearts who are really seeking
the Lord and
honestly the the Bible tells us that our
faith is cons by hearing and hereby the
word of God so what he's already doing
which is good to study the scriptures is
is a good thing to study to learn but I
I will say that he has to remember that
it is the holy spirit that teaches all
things it's not something that you know
you or I can say oh listen to me and
you'll heal no there's another way the
the actually the in John 14 26 you know
Christ mentions that it is the Holy
Ghost
that will come and teach all things and
remind you all things that he said so
it's important to remind him that first
he has to ask the Holy Spirit to lead
him and then I will suggest that he
should start with the conflict of the
ages series
and one thing that I remember as a young
man when I was in in even an academy I
heard from a professor or a teacher I
think was actually a week of prayer or
uh or a Revival week that we had and it
was this pastor I believe or Professor I
can remember exactly who he was at this
point but he mentioned something
interesting he said every time you start
reading Ellen's white book
um highlight in the book he started to
say with better than prophets which is
the first book of the great you know the
configuration series and highlight every
time she has a Bible verse you know link
there there's a lot of times and you'll
realize the
just how much she quotes scripture just
how much the scripture is in it and as
you start your devotional life your your
research and you highlight all the
places that she writes or she's quotes
scripture you will be able to connect
and grow in your understanding of the
scriptures
through the light that the lord gave
sister white uh conflict of the ages
series uh this uh young man might not
know what that is so basically it's the
five books where Ellen White goes from
uh the fall of Lucifer in heaven to the
end of the conflict it's uh basically
Patriarchs and Prophets prophets and
Kings Desire of Ages Acts of the
Apostles and great controversy I would
say when you're reading scripture and
when you're reading the writings of
Ellen White come with a come with a
humble heart and say Speak Lord for your
servant heareth amen and that means not
only hearing it means putting into
practice what you learn at any given
moment amen uh secondly ask the Lord for
wisdom in prayer never should we open
the Bible without prayer that's right
and then in the third place you know as
you continue reading the scriptures as
you continue reading the writings of
Ellen White things will get clearer and
clearer absolutely you know I have
somebody here at Secrets unsealed Larry
pyburn who answers Bible questions
well when he started answering Bible
questions he would call me all the time
for me to tell him where I could find
the answer but now he hardly ever calls
me right because he's been into the
Bible into the spirit of Prophecy so
much that it's become second nature and
so continue reading the Bible I would
recommend Andrew continue reading the
spirit of Prophecy right when you don't
have when you have something that you
don't understand
take a moment to ask the Lord for wisdom
lord I can't understand this help me
please to understand it amen so anyway
our time is up thank you so much for
joining us today for I'd like to know
hope to see you next time on this very
important program
[Music]
foreign